În acest capitol vom explora
cum calculatoarele cuantice și clasice
lucrează împreună pentru a rezolva una dintre cele mai importante provocări
din știință: estimarea cu precizie a energiei moleculelor și materialelor
Putem realiza asta
folosind un quantum circuit
pentru a genera exemple de baze
pe care le vom post-procesa
și le vom diagonaliza printr-o serie de algoritmi
din această familie de rutine
precum SQV, SKG și există un curs întreg pe
platforma IBM Quantum dedicat
lor și metodelor asociate
În scopul acestei prezentări vom
oferi o explicație scurtă
indiferent dacă folosești SQV sau SKG
scopul tău este să găsești vectorii proprii
și valorile proprii ale unei matrice hamiltoniene
Această matrice poate descrie energia unui sistem fizic
sau chimic, dar același cadru
poate aborda multe alte tipuri de probleme
precum logistica, uneori
aceste matrice sunt enorme
deci reducerea dimensiunilor
matricei, păstrând în același timp caracteristici importante
ale stării fundamentale
poate fi extrem de valoroasă — acesta este scopul în SQV
Folosim calculatorul cuantic pentru a genera un subspațiu util
care conține starea fundamentală
Putem apoi să proiectăm matricea noastră hamiltoniană
pe acel subspațiu, ceea ce ne lasă
cu o matrice mai mică, care va fi
mult mai ușor de diagonalizat
folosind calcul clasic de înaltă performanță; facem asta
pregătind o stare cuantică de test
numită adesea ansatz
și efectuând măsurători pentru a eșantiona acel ansatz
în baza computațională, ceea ce ne oferă
un subspațiu eșantionat în baza computațională
Dar ceea ce vrem cu adevărat să găsim
este adevărata stare fundamentală; ce se întâmplă
dacă subspațiul nostru eșantionat nu conținea
toate componentele necesare?
Dacă alegem un ansatz mai bun
am putea obține o estimare mai bună a stării fundamentale
Asta ne conduce la abordarea bazată pe eșantionare
Krylov cuantic sau SKUDY; în SKUDY
pornim cu un ansatz
ca înainte, dar apoi aplicăm niște quantum gates care aproximează
evoluția în timp a unui sistem fizic
Se poate demonstra că, cu câteva ipoteze
asta duce la garanții privind suprapunerea dintre evoluția în timp a
ansatz-ului și adevărata stare fundamentală
Ambii acești algoritmi pornesc cu matrice
hamiltoniene enorme; funcționează oarecum diferit
dar în ambele cazuri partea cuantică a algoritmului produce
un subspațiu care ne permite să reducem matricea
în care sperăm să păstrăm caracteristicile cheie ale stării fundamentale
Deci unde intervine calculul clasic de înaltă performanță
pentru cele mai mari matrice hamiltoniene
și pentru cele mai precise estimări ale stării fundamentale?
Chiar și aceste matrice proiectate pot fi destul de mari
Prin urmare, valorificarea capacităților unor calculatoare clasice mai puternice
ne poate ajuta nu
doar să obținem rezultate mai bune
ci și permițându-ne să abordăm probleme mai mari
Pentru a lega totul
putem reprezenta algoritmii bazați pe eșantionare
ca o combinație de modele de programare diferite
pe un set de resurse heterogene
De exemplu, putem reprezenta algoritmul nostru
ca un flux de sarcini unde vom avea o sarcină
pentru pregătirea quantum circuit-ului care se suprapune
cu starea noastră țintă, urmată de o sarcină
pentru transpiler, care necesită doar resurse clasice
de executat; în continuare va fi sarcina
care folosește primitive pentru a executa quantum circuit-ul nostru
care evident
și apoi vom avea o sarcină de post-procesare care la rândul ei
poate fi un algoritm de diagonalizare paralelă
rulând pe mai multe noduri
În plus, am putea dori să rulăm
unul dintre acești algoritmi de mai multe ori
în timp ce variem ansatz-ul nostru
sau să le rulăm complet în paralel
cu populații diferite
Acum să legăm totul cu SKUDY
în cod: iată toate fișierele noastre de sarcini
și iată toate fișierele noastre de trimitere
În sarcina de mapare pregătim circuit-urile.
În pasul de optimizare rulăm circuit-urile în cel mai bun mod.
În sarcina de execuție eșantionăm bitstringuri
din starea pregătită de
circuit-ul nostru ISA.
Pe care îl obținem din pasul anterior
și facem post-procesarea noastră.
Deci acum suntem gata să trimitem
fluxul nostru de lucru SKUDY.
După cum poți vedea, totul rulează în secvență
cu dependențe; să așteptăm
rezultatele și putem verifica fișierele de ieșire.
Iată fișierul de ieșire al pasului de optimizare
unde avem circuit-ul nostru ISA.
Și să verificăm în final
iterația noastră.
Din programare.
Și asta e tot pentru demonstrația rapidă a fluxului de lucru SKUDY
tot codul va fi disponibil în secțiunea de text
sau în descrierea de mai jos
și asta e tot; am trecut acum prin câteva
concepte și exemple care te pot ajuta să începi cu
gestionarea programelor hibride complexe; desigur
dacă vrei asta abia zgârie suprafața a
tot ce poți face cu combinația de resurse cuantice
și clasice specifice; pentru a explora mai mult
verifică documentația și tutorialele
de pe platforma IBM Quantum
și asigură-te că verifici resursele din secțiunea de text
sau descriere pentru mai multe articole
și software; mulțumesc că ai urmărit.
Da, asta e.